يزيد ينضم الينا من تونس مراسلنا نور
الدين امباركي اهلا بك يا نور الدين
التفاصيل معك نور الدين بشان هذه
المظاهره التي تم تاجيرها
همم قبل دقائق فقط رئيس جامعه الخلاص
وايضا عدد من قيادات جبهه خلاص عقد ونقطه
اعلانيه امام المسرح البلدي وصل العاصمه
حيث كان المفروض ان تنتظمه المظاهره التي
تمت الدعوه اليها واكد ان قياده جبهه
الخلاص قررت تاجيل هذه المظاهره وذلك على
خلفيه رفض السلطات ان يتم ادخال مكبرات
الصوت الى هذه المظاهره انهم لا يحملون
ترخيصا في ذلك وقال احمد نجيب الشيبي ان
قياس تستطيع ايثاره صوتها في ظل غياب هذه
المخابرات الصوت لذلك قرروا تاجيل هذه
المظاهره الى وقت لاحق دون ان يحدد موعد
لذلك كان المفروض ان تنطلق قبل نصف ساعه
من الان هذه المظاهره وذلك تحت عنوان
لكاميرين رفيق العنوان الاول هو يتعلق
باستعاده الديمقراطيه وهو شعار الرئيس
لجبهه الخلاص فيما يتعلقوا بعوده الشرعيه
وايضا الدعوه مقاطعه انتخابات التشريعيه
هناك ايضا شعار جديد وهو من اجل الحلم
عربي واحد وهذا الشعار هو احاله او نوع من
الدعم للدعوات التي رفعت في مصر لاتظاهر
اليوم 11 نوفمبر احمد نجيب الشامي قال في
النقطه الاعلاميه بان ضروره مسانده هذه
التحركات باعتبار ان هناك توجه من اجل ما
اعتبره محاوله وقت الثورات العربيه التي
انطلقت موضه 2011 نعم شكرا جزيلا لك نور
الدين المبارك مراسيلنا من تونس على
التفاصيل شكرا نوردين